thank you to expressvpn for sponsoring
this video more on them after the
reaction citizens of the reject Nation
it's me Tara Ericson and John
humy that's me hi guys we're W we're she
PTI we're watching Madagascar 3 are you
guys ready we're we're doing this whole
Shang I mean I feel ready he feels ready
what have you got to say to the People
John do you have any updates I just that
you know America's Most Wanted piece of
content is our reaction to Europe's Most
Wanted so you know we're just here to
deliver we are people Pleasers at the
reject Nation we are so you better leave
a like you better get in there you
better leave a comment and also don't
forget you could do it with me ring the
bell ring the bell oh my gosh John on
the freaking Harmony y'all he's so
musically
inclined don't forget uh we thank prer
for helping us edit down these videos a
bit we appreciate you also we call you
super sexy if you get on that patreon
get on it get sexy you can sync up with
your own copy watch all M Madagascar 3
with us also John and grank have
exclusive highlights and watch alongs
over there on patreon and what else have
I forgotten go to reject Nation reation
shop.com grab yourselves some official
reject Nation swag supports the channel
we got the space babies of the Galaxy we
got uh the what's appropriate uh Child
Protection Services we got the the the
these Snips all sorts of lovely designs
for you guys they have the best t-shirts
and they're also very very comfortable I
have two of them and they are literally
the best I get compliments on my child
protection services t-shirt all the
time all right should we just get into
this we're going to get into
it
okay oh that looks like my
shirt DreamWorks bound this is closer up
though it's like a extreme closeup of
the DreamWorks thing this kid better be
ready this time he got jumped last time
you going to get snatched by
Boy my man made it safe this time loving
it oh we're back at the beautiful
landscape of Africa hey wind you're up
boys they built it Carlo or
buap check Monte Carlo we'll be back my
gambling free in a couple weeks oh
whenever the gold out byee they're just
picking up right where we left off again
yeah exactly we're never coming back
sorry what was that initiate War Drive
who what did they just say they were
never coming back oh no well this is a
nightmare Alex is in an alternate
Dimension the Multiverse oh what are you
here what you is to on this I'm
hungry
waa I'm just messing with you I lost all
feeling in this thing years ago oh no I
want a blinky eyeball
balloon look who's talking Gloria why
are you guys so
elderly
noake up Marty Marty it was horrible
you're all super old and wrinkly and
well I aged well but the rest of you
look
terrible of course have they come to
take us home nope but it's the next best
thing another day bites the dust come on
now another one dust Another
one then just over this
blil what is it oh okay happy birthday
pal H you're going in the dying
pit oh they built him a little city New
York New York that's so
sweet oh my goodness ah he's the bridge
I love that your huddled masses baby and
melin you're the Brooklyn Bridge
actually I'm the trior bridge oh yes of
course hey Fifth Avenue with no traffic
Time Square with its modern-day
corporate lack of character yes
get that
marketing and the zoo the beautiful
little Zoo there's a little me and
little all of uses oh no I I have a deep
love in my heart for tiny versions of
things if he picks one up I will be done
[Music]
for to be back in New York where
people's whole lives revolve around the
zoo they love the zoo so much they don't
even go to
work make wish
sweetheart
oh of course Oh yay my tummy is speaking
to
me oh my goodness where are we are we
pre orost uh rainbow vomiting gnome but
it's not the real thing well that's
because it's a mud model Alex it's not
New York I hope that was clear the real
Center needs to be at least three times
as big as this also he hung off one of
those buildings and I was like how is
that not breaking apart a giraffe and a
hippo walk into a casino in Monte Carlo
I don't know ask the rabbi hey I'm
serious it's us we're us yeah to mon
Carlo they go to home home home home
cheeseburger that too love them extra
pickles yeah they're probably bored out
of their mind oh
yeah
this is what's happening in The Hangover
while the guys are passed
out pillows are filled with baby birds
this is how I want every party of mine
to go and it never ends up there what a
such a disappointment you got to throw
madag gasar party it's the missing link
ter that's my next
theme nice faux Mission Impossible music
it's so pretty there I want to go to the
monteo god they got there
immediately found that's where we'll
find the
[Music]
Penguins bing bing I'm a SC man talking
really really
quiet
[Applause]
[Music]
gotcha of course oh dude you're going to
have like a residency you're going to
get Monte Carlo moving it moving it we
apologize to the Penguins for overly
harsh chewing outing but
we've gotten our point across absolutely
phase four back to New York City this is
how I map out every
confrontation and then he never does it
nope it's just enough to get it out you
how much duct each of us should
take I love how quick moving this is
like already off the bat I'm really
liking
it
whoa oh yeah
tough oh okay and out that makes more
sense oh she's going to get
stuck oh or maybe
[Laughter]
not hi honey yeah got us got us hi honey
honey I'm
home
yes I love
this mission impossible so expect some
kind kind of
Disguise wa look at that that is one
ugly mugly lady that is roach killing
ugly
ug ugly mugly Veri that's the chimps and
The Chimps are like smoke and where
there's smoke there's fire and by fire I
mean the
Penguins of course can we buy an Airbus
A380 solid gold baby solid gold plane
wouldn't be able to fly wski will be
rich the rules of physics don't apply to
us that's true very true exactly 2
minutes and 17 seconds the Lemur will
cut the power
no no no do it no these are things a
leader has to think of these cutto are
great that's it who voted you Grand pH
Master anyway I voted me oh golly guys
uh oh is he gonna have to dance to after
they start
screaming I am a doctor no no why can't
we all be leav I'm going to leave oh
there we go all of them cut to the
chase no no just just do some moves
start
dancing watch new cat oh oh man we
are so sorry well apology accepted let's
roll let's roll over
switch okay
F ug
cool I love this editing this is great
what you want what you really
want we get a new song I really want to
want to Z a
[Music]
sick I have finally reached the moment I
have been preparing for my entire life
sheers of my career to hunt the king of
the
Beast
yes oh I hate her already
yep oh no lock down e those are some
Purge
walls I got this one crossover yeah or
Ethan Hawk
[Music]
woof
W what amazing where are we what is this
we call it the luxury assault
recreational vehicle the caros vro Vroom
yes it do just going to say that's a
very stylish baby seat it is and the
license plat says eat cake
oh was that a
Kos or is that a Ferrari ferar old
Ferrar not Lamborghini it's a
Ferrari High School John is really mad
at me right
now
and then they went to hell for kids nice
transition into our
village
oh the super smeller whoa she's like a
[Music]
spider oh my what I wish this was
released in smell a vision that would be
fun
at
12:00 oh man that's going to be so hard
to fit on your wall don't take any
phot hi here I
am in the bum always in the bum we have
the wheel are you kidding I don't drive
I'm a New
Yorker what are you doing zebras can't
drive only penguins and people can drive
yes of course it's the laws of
nature yes they just added a cartoon Bo
in there anyway you want
itate
activate who
what oh slipping and
sliding this
lady nice too late for you to drive look
at me don't look at me when we argue
look at cool be
cool is there a problem hi
oh oh wow how this moment is
[Music]
aged oh the villain reminds me of
Angelica Houston and I want her to have
Angelica Houston's voice but I don't
think she does sitting here like is it
is it Susan sandid who is it uranium 238
blanket
[Music]
okay cool shot
yeah that's cool too good perspectives
there's no break no breaks a way to
commit
Soldier what what about the uranium 238
though wa
who Hotel
Ambassador oh
oh I did not like that that give me to a
little bit let's get out of
here where's everybody
going
a oh no oh no he's on the side of the
building I'm flying I'm playing I'm the
first playing
monkey this music is
great oh beautiful my goodness I love
that on the monkey
chain yes
[Music]
nice reminds me of Diddy
Kong yes Matrix choke for the
kids
Matrix come on
[Music]
milman no cheapers Christ
into it double banana over you could do
it put your back into it come
on oh gosh oh
okay yeah smash her right into that
building let's go no bye-bye lady oh my
gosh dude oh yeah bust through that wall
damn what oh wow she is she's she's ay
woman Brick House
what are you doing yeah hey
nice
bye-bye conveniently placed pool the
gear assembly is badly damaged sir oh
boy yes only a matter of time
before okay yeah before another aerial
crashing
sequence oh but what a pretty sunset hey
where you going back here we have a
contract yes I'm afraid labor laws are
slightly more lenient in France you see
they only have to work 2 weeks a
year we can fix it we'll fix it yeah
guys come on we'll fix it you just start
from the outside pieces and you work
your way in and yeah perfect it was
already pretty bad to begin with Alex no
we just let a montage Let It Go Let It
Go we're never going
home so okay you have a full franchise
based on this very principle the finale
of the franchise is when they go back to
New York finally what are we going to do
we can't hide forever and we can't just
blend you noce say in Africa oh what's
the point oh they're going to be join us
circus I love it
[Music]
perfect oh yeah please you got to hide
us just until the heat dies down
absolute no Outsiders so wipe that
smearing off your face and pop off man
you got to do one cat a solid cat to cat
do a solid here buddy cuz we are
great I don't trust lion hair too big
and glossy I come on supp to move Alex
he just takes care of himself man hey
lion lioness man's got the moves all
right that's what matters so what
counts just to give us a minute he's on
the phone and I can't get him off uh he
wasn't listen we are circus animals you
got to let us
in oh oh is this a new love
connection best
believe stick
together yes yes oh I love that she has
a little heart on her paw that's right
we are all descendants of Andy Circus
and descendants of Andy Circus stick
together indeed you must all be a very
famous
yeah we uh absolutely but Alex is really
the star well I'm not I wouldn't say
star more more like more like well star
you know you wanted to I well I roar
like really like but like a serious
like then then I jump off the rock that
is into a pool full of water full of
cobras how do you do that wire harness
balloons jet pack well all the above I
flip off the wire harness ignite my
Jetpack and then toss balloons to the
children the war world kids love it mhm
hey I have a great idea maybe you come
up with us Toom this is going to be like
the exact opposite problem of last time
he's not going to be able to perform
well enough yeah after Roma we go to
London and then a big time promoter will
see us and then send us to New York
a isn't that fun who we go with you you
can bunk with a
t big dude's not a jerk he just doesn't
want to get their hopes up one rule we
do not circus owner no allow
STS whoa what the H oh it's them he knew
it was them although the circus owner
may allow STS if the starways just
happen to be the owners riddle me
that oh yeah oh hey
hey you you have a deal amigo oh my well
well well they bought the circus oh but
they won't have any clowns that's messed
up
dude oh no oh
no yep leave a
like get it get it get it hey okay I
like a good train beat
sequence hey this is not first class n
cuz of the airplane last time with the
skeleton with the tin can
hat and all that fruit oh it's a Saw
movie though oh yeah all
[Music]
right that's
funny oh yes oh I love this
spooky oh what what are we doing here
okay
[Music]
oh everyone's going to find love this
movie Melman and Gloria broke the damn
for
everybody
[Music]
ah hey gus has anyone ever told you that
you look like a supermodel orbe it a fat
hairy one hey man we've come a long way
anybody can be a model yeah you have a
very veryy work I like that in a
woman it's okay guys we don't we don't
shame around here
no oh oh dude banana amunition that
that's paperwork at the very
least oh boy she
isy too much
conditioner that M tail on there she was
engineer in some laboratory she
definitely was nobody crawls like that
yeah she's got animal on so high so run
away with the circus what a
cliche oh
boy is wow okay is she some sort of
Terminator yeah we're going to figure it
out she's living out like an edge of
tomorrow she's done the Live Die Repeat
on this situation so many times that she
just knows it every single beat
yeah what a dump they want to attract a
decent sports team why are there no
circuses anymore I would totally go to a
circus no I wouldn't cuz the animals in
it I don't like it I just changed my
mind if the Penguins own the circus if
the Penguins own the circus I would go
to the circus yeah my ancestors used to
perform here kid
yeah no kid a would you look at this you
got to go back to your mama up what up
boy where off you Muppet wow Marty
they're professionals come
on you call him a muppet guys stop
fooling around we're just having a
little fun let's let these animals do
their
show they should be in the show oh my
goodness I love it Afro Circus AF AF po
poka poka
afro really yes
really Vatican oh yes we need this
this Union ordained by the pope oh
wow oh my God Andrea belli is in this
yep
[Music]
yep boad gascar
boy oh
yeah
pour one out that was
heav put a her bike I would get you
something even
[Music]
better super easy barely an
inconvenience dude buddy that is that is
a bad that's a that's a trip to HR we
now say that I don't want
you I don't want you to think of me as
some sort of authority
figure don't worry I don't you don't oh
not at all nobody is intimidated at all
by you if anything they're starting to
feel sorry for you okay this circus
means everything to us and if you do
anything that threatens the circus you
will have to answer to me I like her
Crystal
we're Crystal
capy hey oh in the throws of love but
it's really in the throws of threat
don't let tiger guy catch you where
there C there
lion and when in
Rome evil AR ah yes
absolutely oh not bad W not not
[Music]
bad I I like that their you know just
like lack of involvement with
money has perpetuated certain elements
of this plot yeah now you're really
really in a big
TR she's got to be
out the
[Music]
finger Alex you have so much to teach
these
guys no kid going get
CR oh my God they didn't they did they
they they did oh he has to come out of
there I legit never thought I would see
that oh no no this is not
happening you have a
deal get that gold back we got to get
into circus training stat they're
demanding their money back I think we
all know the right thing to
do
[Music]
teamwork melman's neck is like the MVPs
yeah L the
money give me the whip
[Music]
no but I guess also yeah like good Fair
now you have to really work and earn
your money that's
true ah yep yep yep do they know about
the old escape a hole behind the
innocent a looking
poster no stupid going to hide up on the
ceiling a
trick good knows physics the secet of
the tongue under the bed get thing it's
Alcatraz all over again yeah let's
go love it dude killing the game all
right you must have some left over I
used it to bite tea now I can eat apples
sadly I discovered I I don't like apples
that's disturbing
[Laughter]
yep so happy he was happy all right
happy he'll have a plan yeah I just
realized we bought a circus they were so
close that it's We Bought a Zoo that
would have fixed all the problems yeah
it's comad Damon to your
[Music]
head oh yeah it is a Miss
possible
who nice performing at his best in a
[Music]
crisis go okay so it used to be good
they used to be good or maybe it's just
a li the tiger he was the biggest star
ever saw he was Fearless taking a risks
always new he jump to the hoop like he
could fly this voice is driving me nut I
know who who who that
is
yes like
a oh yeah oh wow oh yeah let's do this
thing oh
no wa and he was never the same it was
physically
impossible and the people they
LED okay what yeah what what happened
cuz they're all still alive I thought
maybe somebody died it's going to be
revealed that he's doing hoop steroids
she got the smaller like on the finger
of the tiniest lady with his sish
fingers the POV with the sound effect
just died yeah oh my god oh boy oh my
God light the hoop on
fire
oh oh my
God nice nice choice
colors I like when this movie goes kind
of trippy yeah and subjective wow he's
adding a gymnastics act before as well
oh everyone's Tails wagon oh and then he
caught on fire right he also was covered
in olive oil you guys come on and he
lost everything his wife she run off
with the musician what and when it grow
back it is has a soft
s nothing he's bitter and bruised it's
Martin Short I think oh I think you're
right I think this is Martin this is why
we need your help what sort of help you
can teach us to do new circus yes cuz
the sounds like him it is stupid idea we
are lost
cin no this is stupido this could work
be a great circus again people have a
comeback we are going to rethink
everything anybody's ever known about
circus yes this is where Alex does Alex
will come up with something fresh
something amazing something brand new
something that'll blow that circus
promoter away on the chain wax family's
not so entertained because you're just
going through the motions out there want
to have passion for stool poent face
exactly and by stool you mean chair
right think real hard circus is about
following your passions wherever they
take you you cannot change circus there
is long tradition you you incorporate
the traditions of the new stuff now they
play Vegas 50 shows a day in 52 separate
venues and one of them completely in the
nude oh that's right they do have a zity
right yeah they cannot take the animals
out of the
circus I mean they cannot circus out of
the I think you understand what I'm
saying yeah we do we we'll put him back
because if we follow our passion we can
go any anywhere anywhere we can do
anything if we do it together all of us
together
together love it we can do that funking
groove dance thing dance this thing
right here
look me and
you yes this could be our last chance
but we will not do this without you
circus always stay it together one of us
one of us come on shape up or ship out
but shape up I do one hoop
yay he I mean the Hoops a classic anyway
what do you got to complain about I have
found a lion he is hiding with the
suus going to have to do it solo lady
not that you've needed them up until
you're a Terminator I don't even know
why you're over there asking for their
help
yes wish I oh wow whoa I took more
French
classes wow wow what she's like singing
them back to
[Music]
health is this a musical
reference like a showstopper from lay
Miz or something could be that is that
would be a good guess so pretty
Gorge the perfect place for circus
training I've always dreamed of doing
this is it dangerous is it dangerous oh
my yes of course it's dangerous oh my
God blowing up is your thing then you in
the right place see that's means yes
love this what a show the TNT
seal oh Christ oh
[Music]
you are going to die oh oh good your
teeth are still in there good stretch
Zoom o Rico get the Canon ready save
charge oh oh I love
[Music]
that the flying zebra yeah cool you're
finding your act man amazing now go save
your your
[Music]
friend love
that today rbow w a
rainbow I would love it if Marty just
like flies off into another dimension Al
together and never returns yes I don't
think I can hold on much longer oh oh
yeah right sorry about my enthusiasm is
here wrap this around boy wow my guy
that scary don't drop him hey
a all right I got you I got
you
yay yeah Marty to the rescue my man I'm
going to be part of the flock I'm going
to fly baby yes you are got this
Martin oh I admire how you have inspired
these animos oh thanks and what you said
about the passion it was like poetry I
love passion and poetry they go together
really m
you can teach me oh well you know I've
always been kind of a solo act so that
kind of rules that out I wonder if you
actually do tra oh I actually do do
traes show me you've got to prove it
prove it you want excitement ha check it
out who's on a TI rope huh huh who's on
a wowe oh my gosh baby hold on hold on
I'm coming right now oh my
God n man n man oh oh wow look at him go
come to me I I can't it's just like
dancing Melman two steps forward one
step back I can't dance okay maybe
because you've never tried no I have
tried a I practiced in private because
you danced so well you practiced a
that's so sweet all you have to do is
put them around your partner yeah M two
steps forward one step back everyone's
going to find their act so cute we're
getting close to a circus act a full one
yes in fact you need a push
watch oh look at that you got pretty
lucky oh wow what a professional So
[Music]
Graceful
life has a
twist from who is
singing the skies in this movie are so
pretty yeah we have to try to find our
own future with you at sounds like Neil
Patrick Harris singing yeah even though
I don't think it
[Music]
is love senorita bell
bottoms bra Grande oh no damn
it oh no she's she on to us she is she's
a beast she's yeah are you sure that we
are ready of course we're ready Born
Ready Ready Steady come on let's go
let's go go go go go ready steady go
grab your luggage and drain your
bladders it's going to be a long ride
there no bathroom on this train a new
paint job a new act notice he does not
have his birth mark in this movie oh
yeah his little Africa paw birthmark
have we just not seen that hand or we
have yet I think we have huh looking for
it before I demand this level of
continuity
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah the Ring of Death it's going to do
numbers going give you PTSD you got to
find a new act that and this also got to
be really triggering for people who have
that phobia of like lots of little holes
lots of little circles a little circle
hole yikes London
England
wowe whoa they made it look so much
cooler on the outside yeah looks like
waville ohy that's not a red blooded
American promoter I don't know what is
yeah hey Stephano have you seen
vital hey oh no what happened they ran
away wipe away the tears calm down where
is he I'm sure I can reason with him
yeah whoa you're leaving you're just
going to walk out on everybody they have
good show without me you're afraid man
what happened to Circus stick together
huh Show Must Go On cliches you may have
given up on yourself but your friends
haven't given up on you are you just
going to turn your back on them and sit
and eat borch the rest of your life or
are you going to get out there and jump
through that tiny little hoop oh no his
birth mark is there it's just more
subtle it was always impossible to tell
to that's why the people L A that is why
I loved it because I did the impossible
my man yeah think I might have we found
his passion yeah great not olive oil
perfect love
[Music]
that it's
okay yes
[Music]
yes all right all right man all right
man let's do it you've got this yes
I'm
oo yeah let's go do a barrel
roll you get stuck oh you went
through wow my man amazing man you did
it you got the groove back you got your
groove back you like to groove it groove
it he likes to groove it groove it we
got a show to put on let's go go go go
go go this is just the pre-show
entertainment love it
oh now he's going to do a pole
[Music]
dance night
like
[Music]
work oh man oh
man whoa dang this this is quite the
show this is really cir inspired
[Music]
a now it's one of those video games
where you tap the
beat look at you go fireworks every last
one of
you this is what the construct of the
Multiverse looks like in this universe
in this world yeah in the Madagascar
Cinematic Universe just like to think
there's a subtle element of that we were
in like the gray dreary place at one
point we were in Marty's like Dreamland
at one point now this we're going to
America today right now wow that was
quick Al and we did pretty good you will
flip and I will catch and sometimes I
will flip oh he's going to be like I
have to go back to the zoo right always
be around where are you going well I'm
I'm I'm oh god oh jeez my past is
catching up with me Miss we both know
Zion does not belong to you is that
hardd woman they've all kind
fores on my
[Music]
wall I hate her kill her right now yeah
Bond penguins in action oh yes oh yeah
yes here we go explode her into space
launch them all except this time it's
just body parts and
Vis you are from a zoo you you performed
every day you did dance moves and stuff
he said he got on his Rock and you know
we had to say we were circus you never
have let us on the train your name is
not even Alison no Steph no but it never
really was and I tried to tell you we
trusted you my tears are real but but
you not but you just buil a big circus
show he just catapulted you to like
major success I get you're going to be
big big stars I get it no means no on
your
language oh my oh boy not everything is
solved that way you know oh oh my oh my
oh boy what are we doing for the kids
right now yeah what is wrong with you
[Music]
speak she could go to the zoo I want to
come along for the rest of the franchise
it's obvious I'm just an emotional
whooping C
for you to sit
on Time
to Say
[Music]
Goodbye sweet girl I love her barice or
whatever your name is we have sure to do
but how do I go on without Marty you can
still do Canon solo I want to do a solo
act with myy no a he misses his friend
we can do impossible yeah and we never
go back to way we used to be you tell
them used to be is it the way it was and
it won't be the same without them it's
okay in New York now though the circus
yeah it looks like they've okay so
they'll obviously show up to help them
right I mean I or I don't know or maybe
they'll just be like the zoo ain't that
cool let's go back my rock looks smaller
than I remember it doesn't actually
capture the real thing does
it I forgot about that wall in between
us M mhm was that always there home's
not home anymore you've seen too much
grown too far you've lived a lot leaving
the zoo was the best thing that ever
happened to us out there in the world we
were really living yeah it was exciting
it was romantic it was dangerous
when we were with a circus we were
already home I wish we'd realized that
sooner and now they'll never take us
back we make it right by telling them
how wrong we were it's worth a shut if
we go down in flames so be
it oh
no and back
into the zoo they oh my
God he will never fit in the carry on
but his head will wow wow how did you
ever get put in in official position
involving animals you brought back Alex
the Lion thank you thank
you where are you oh no baby forgive me
oh
hello it's boy Baba buoy Baba buoy where
did you get this I got it from the zoo
the hippies got ambushed what we have to
help them but they Li to us yeah why
should we lift the poor they are our
friends look where you are they built
that with you Al where are you oh of
course no more Open Air Zoo who brought
Alex the lion and a couple of three
three other animals come on like you
don't remember the three other
[Music]
animals oh
oh oh my God poison what what is going
on
no it was never
about it was
about
[Applause]
jeez
[Music]
wa
Afro Circus yeah let's go unleash the
seal I am a SE whatever oh I watched a
whole video on the difference
once that's something John would
do nice now how are they going to get
him out of those cages yes wowe oh
awesome got it yes love
[Music]
it
yes wow
wow love
that
whoa jeez man suck in that
gut
who they did it oh my God this is going
to be the best promo you could ever hope
for circus is going to blow up after
this circus and the zoo should just merg
people already love the zoo that much
yeah oh SN oh this God oh my
[Music]
gosh help me I will head help
me come on man the snakes that's the
snakes it's the enactment whole thing
the whole nine it's a great call back
afro don't fail me
now that afro is a damn American hero
and so are you Mar
[Music]
take stano into the sea of Cobra she
goes I am going down your head is coming
with me I
don't oh let's go
yes cool your days of chasing animals
are over
duah
oh my God wa put her in the human Zoo
this is where animals like you belong
now
sit
light
oh W that was so
great
a in love so you uh want to run away
with the circus live a life of of
Adventure full of romance a danger
really Le what do you say
yes
cus AF circus circus afro
circus that's a fun call back that was a
good shot in the first
movie Freedom
fries two one that was a good call back
wow that was quite an experience that
was boy this one moved a lot faster for
me uh I like the pacing a lot better and
I loved the the editing too um as well
as the music there was switch up in
there was like a switch up with the
music like a bunch um and that was yeah
I just felt like it moved quicker and I
like that yeah big thanks to expressvpn
for sponsoring this video a real game
changer I've been using for years that's
right years so whenever they want to
work with us it's an instant yes you've
likely heard about expressvpn for online
privacy and security but there's more to
it than that however there was a very
real incident recently with Spectrum
Shing on my internet and contacting me
due to a suspecting hacking attempt and
funny enough I realized I hadn't
actually activated my expressvpn on my
new laptop that I got a couple of months
ago so I was paying the consequences
having faced a serious hacking issue on
YouTube a couple years AG go that made
expressvpn my go-to for both security
and freedom I mean it and yes what
you've heard is true believe me this
channel knows you can use expressvpn to
watch movies and shows on Netflix that
are not available in your country this
means accessing a vast rate of content
of over a 100 countries like a global
Cinema your fingertips it's super easy
open expressvpn switch locations refresh
the browser and there you have it
whether it's kramas on South Korean
Netflix Hulu BBC I player YouTube or
more expressvpn has you covered and it's
incredibly fast ensuring no buffering or
lack for smooth HD streaming it's
versatile too working on not just
computers but phones media consoles
Smart TVs and more this means you can
enjoy your favorite shows on anywhere
any screen protect and elevate your
internet experience so if you want to
get access to hundreds of new shows use
my link expressvpn.com regexs and you
can get an extra 3 months of expressvpn
for free that's
expressvpn.com reex so head to
expressvpn.com reex to learn more thank
you again I like this one I did too I I
I'm not sure which of the sequels I
would prefer ultimately I feel like the
second one moves really fast also and is
like doing a whole lot of things this
one oh Brian
CR was he was he maybe
Vitali oh and Francis Francis MC get out
of
here uh yeah I mean I really like the
places this one wanted to go and like
each time they like cuz I love a good
circus you know um this this one had
like an interesting sort of uh um
structure of events I guess to me
because like the second one like really
hit the ground running and it like
transitioned immediately out of the
first one which this one does also
although I feel like this one moves a
bit more cartoon like I felt more like I
was watching like a smattering of
cartoon episodes with this movie than
like one whole movie like once it really
started to focus on the circus then you
know I was like okay this is this movie
is particular flavor but there's a good
amount of stuff before you get to that
point uh so I think yeah it's it's an
interesting blend because I think the
previous one has the Simplicity of just
like oh everyone's going home
essentially to where they're all from
and and how does that affect everybody
and you've got a couple main plot lines
for each whereas this one is more like
all right we're trying to get back to
New York and and and and everything
keeps going wrong and and oh now we got
the circus and and now we're we're kind
of focused on that for a while after we
get away from uh from what her name but
uh but yeah like I thought it was sweet
and I thought it was fun um I I'm still
I I don't know if I like it more than
the previous one in terms of just like
uh there was never a moment of like lag
in that one whereas like there were
times when this one would be like really
moveing and then I would be a little bit
Jarred by like some kind of change or
something but oh Gia was Jessica
Chastain love wonder who that was um but
yeah no I enjoyed it overall generally
yeah I also feel like the second one had
the heart part of it that we that I
think we said we were missing in the
first the second brought that this one
didn't really have any of those except
for they were falling in love but there
was nothing really that we learned in a
large way I don't think with the
characters it was mostly just like how
do we get home and sure a change of
heart of like we don't actually need to
be at the zoo anymore we found a new
home with the circus which is cool um
but uh yeah I think just really at the
top it it uh CAU my attention a little
bit quicker because I always said that I
like the Penguins a lot and we got to
see them be like Bond Penguins Mission
Impossible and I like that that kept the
the pace of it just moving and grooving
and I liked the the edits in that too
like the cut toos back and forth I
hadn't seen that in the previous movie
of them like cutting to Black and then
um oh yeah they're like speed cutting
through it each time the lights come
back up they're in a new position I I
like that a lot that was enjoyable for
me uh I think it's cute that they have
you know love interests now and um I
guess we'll see what happens with with
zus yes and I liked all the the M there
was more songs in this more music stuff
right it seem like yeah cuz in the first
one You' mainly got that one song and
and New York New York and then this one
you know which got a little I I got worn
out by it so I'm glad that there was new
yeah yeah and eventually you're just
swapping in like firework or something
but but yeah got like that musical
number with um oh goodness oh what what
was her I we got to find out who played
her but uh the evil lady you know we got
her musical number and a couple of
things so yeah like I appreciate that
they uh committed to that and it's like
they always take these interesting
approaches to their story beats in this
one like I think in the last one I said
like there's so many setups that could
go like a bunch of different ways and
and this one was interesting to me
partly because you have the whole thing
about them being authentically C
or not and you have this thing of like
okay they're going to come in and much
like the previous movie they're going to
posture as though like they know what to
do uh and you know how to you know help
the situation or whatever it is and then
we're going to find out that oh no our
four heroes are just woefully unprepared
for this but then you find out beyond
that that even though they're not that
prepared the circus farmers are even
less prepared so then they take on the
role of actually whipping them into
shape which happened successfully which
there's like an odd quality
to like the way they were setting up and
playing with the stakes that I found
very amusing but I I did also find kind
of curious in a way because you have
that whole bit where he's teaching Gia
about trapes and he's just failing his
way through it which I think is fun and
Charming but also kind of left me go
like okay wait a minute like uh it's an
interesting Dynamic but I'm also sort of
maybe slightly taken back by the fact
that it's just like but no he just
pretty much they they teach them how to
do it he's going to succeed despite not
having the the the skills which makes
sense to me in character because he's a
natural showman so like of course he
would figure this out yeah um and I
really enjoyed like watching each of
them find their different Niche like I
thought that was a great device that
sequence of like all the circus
performers like really struggling to you
know find their footing causing each of
Our Heroes to jump in um I guess Gloria
jumps into save mman but but but you
know in each of them kind of engaging
with this and putting out a fire they
find their you know act which I thought
was really fun and Charming um and you
know I mean the the actual circus they
put on you know I've seen some cir do
soles yeah and uh you know it is very
sort of modern and Fantastical and and
even in the way they portray the actual
like the real act that you know wins
everyone's love and affection you know
you're experiencing it it in a
very uh impressionistic kind of way and
this movie had a few of those sequences
where it's like we're going to go full
on Fant Fantastical like animation you
know interlude here yeah you know right
I I find it interesting you you saying
like them playing with like they just
went to the circus and like kind of
farting their way through it and they're
all learning their act but there could
have been another like plot where
they're having to go through that the
people who have been the the people the
the the animals that have been in the
circus for a while had something more to
teach them right that we could have
learned more about our main characters
of them going through something learning
something about uh and maybe bringing
even in a call back to like Alex is
always the star Marty kind of feels left
out I know that I always say his name
wrong Melvin but it's melbin right
melbin and I don't I think it's Melvin
It's Melvin I I'm just going to call
them at Mel and Gloria are like you know
their outskirts like how could we learn
more about them about them arriving at
the circus and learning from these other
circus animals that will carry us
through even more into another plotline
for a future you know Madagascar which I
I mean I'm not saying that's a better
Storyline by any means I'm I'm just I'm
pitching that that that may have been
more interesting to watch that they
would have been through the ringer a
little bit more rather than falling into
it and it being somewhat a success yeah
away it would have maybe felt a little
more like assured or steady or something
yeah and yeah to have that element like
we do get something in return from the
various circus performers but it's not
the same yeah as like oh we really
taught each
other that is one thing that did bother
me the whole time them being like you I
I get being dismayed by you know
somebody making up
their you know they lie to them to to
gain their trust yeah we're circus and
we also know you know how to get you
guys in line you know and I get being
dismayed about that kind of Deceit
however I was I it was hard to look past
the idea of like but they
clearly were they they delivered on
their promise yeah you know and they
clearly elevated you to this thing you
thought was impossible they've
rejuvenated your whole thing it seems
like you are better off than ever before
right and uh and even though the zoo is
different for the circus that that thing
was it felt like when the circus
succeeded the first time in the American
dude came in I thought that was going to
be like oh now the movie is wrapping up
and we're going to go back to America
and and we're going to have our
compromise but there's like a whole
extra Act of like wait no no no we have
to have a the rift when the truth comes
out to the circus performers and we got
to wrap up this stuff with DuBois and uh
and you know all that stuff is fun and I
thought she was fun just as like an
inexplicable character and and a
physical you know presence on screen
that is so animal as compared to
everything else like I think that's a
fun contrast as we have all these
morphed animals you have this incredibly
animal Terminator character pursuing
them uh so you know like I I liked the
stuff we came back to do and seeing yeah
like oh they thought it would be great
to come home but there's the Reckoning
with you know it's not the same once
you've seen what lies beyond your home
it feels a lot smaller and I that was
nice and then also too we're so happy to
have you back now we're going to build
the tallest walls to deter you from ever
uh you know escaping again which like
those I thought were were solid
conflicts for them to be you know sort
of Saved by yeah um but you know it's
it's those little things where it it
then feels like okay well the circus is
like literally next door so that'll help
us get done quick yeah right so yeah so
it's like there are elements that don't
feel quite as smooth to me about this
experience than the previous ones but or
more difficult or thought through where
it seems easy like the plot line seems
very easily linked like oh we'll just do
this and make it quick or like that
which um
or like in the beginning like you know
it's like we got to go find the Penguins
now and like the last one sets you up
like we're going to get to the next
major location that's going to motivate
lots of the plot and we're going to make
that the part of the journey whereas
this one they're like we got to go find
the Penguins we're at we're in Monaco
now so it was so quick um so certain
certain moments like that yeah don't
feel quite as smoothed over but like
yeah there's there's still a whole bunch
of what they went for here that I enjoy
and that appeals to me and that I had
fun fun like the cast is still lovely
together and the new additions for the
most part I thought did a fine job yeah
totally I mean I'd give it a six and a
half uh that's probably my my rating for
it because it was still it's like fun
quick moving um I think like as I always
say just a little more heart like what
there was there could have been
something that really just got me where
it's like somebody's learning something
and they all like change together I
don't know I really like that yeah um
and so that's why at 6.5 for me yeah
yeah if they had maybe smoothed out some
of the character stuff this this one
seemed the lightest in terms of like
actually you
know focusing in on like the character
stuff and more intent on like you know
set pieces and and you know wackiness
which is which is fine like and then the
characters still grow and everything but
but this one didn't yeah feel quite as
finessed as the other two in terms of
how the story was moving I guess right
um but yeah who who who did we have here
before we get out of here who did we
have as a okay Jessica Chastain was Gia
yeah okay and uh and Francis mcdorman
was dubis oh love that so yeah I
wouldn't have picked her out but that's
uh and then yeah I was gonna say oh
Brian Cranson was Vitali yeah yeah and
then I I was thinking like okay Vinnie
Jones was one of the dogs that was the
other thing I was thinking is like you
got to have like a who's who of like
British tough guys to be the dogs um so
yeah it's like I feel like if movie had
maybe been I liked the stuff they did to
get us to the circus but maybe if this
whole movie had focused mostly on the
circus MH and maybe we could have had
more flesh on those you know characters
like really feeling it yeah cuz when you
set up at the end you're like you know
we're all going to continue together you
know like it's not quite I think as
exciting as it should be to be like oh
we're going to have all the new guys
along with us now yeah cuz we didn't
give enough time apart that they really
like missed them what did they go go
through what's the journey that they
felt without them like how was it
difficult how much did you learn while
you were there in the circus from each
other and then you get separated and
then you have to live in that separation
for a second I think a be longer so that
when the pullback happens it's like more
Bittersweet yeah and stuff to bond us
more directly to the circus characters
in like just moments that are a little
more like we get kind of the most of
that with Stephano and to a degree we
get that with with Vitali but you know
like I think they could have maybe
there's there's so many characters
there's a lot going on there's a lot I
can't even don't even know how he knows
those names there's definitely not a
list of them in front of me rolling off
John's tongue yeah
yeah so well I mean that's that's the
other thing is you know it again I
enjoyed much of this but I think it is a
testament it's like characters are
you're much more likely to remember
their name if they're really you know uh
taking the time to really you know
connect you to them in some way shape or
form so this is like fun to watch all
these guys I liked everybody and it was
but it but it felt the most like I was
watching episodes of a cartoon rather
than uh like a rounded movie it it felt
like a cartoon that kept reminding
itself like oh no no no we're we're we
got to be our movie though yeah which is
fine which you know I like this
tradition of stuff so yeah what he said
what's your rating give it give it a go
before we get out of here you give it
like six and a half yeah okay I love it
and don't forget oh wow optimistic uhh a
good time still look at him go and I
forgot to say this at the top someone's
going to have to edit this in if you're
listening to this on Apple or Spotify
please rate this we love you give us
ratings and if you're on the tubes or on
the patreon you know like comment tell
us how cool we are tell us your thoughts
on the movie we love to hear from you uh
I don't know give us follows on social
media all the junk you know
I'm follow us and do stuff are we going
to do a patron shout out I think we
should maybe we're prepping we're
prepping let's do it who do we want to
shout out let get her done I like Kevin
Smart's name Okay Kevin Smart's name and
then we'll do uh let's see uh let's do
Kevin smart and
Lex and uh let's go to good old chat GPT
Tera Erics all right so um hey agree
listen chat
GPT um I have a YouTube
channel and I want to give a shout out
to some of our patrons AKA super sexy
rejects write me a scene what would we
do we got be a circus scene yeah okay so
um um uh only dialogue using these
circus elements uh Tara give me some
circus trap trap trap
canonball
Cannonball and maybe the French people
there um how's about
um uh what did you have one the Cobra
the a cobra I'm just going to put a
cobra in there Cobra is good oh yeah
yeah the Snake Charmer did you mean that
like a snake charmer yeah Snake Charmer
uh stray peanut shells
everywhere um and was there some things
you don't expect at a at a circus
Tera um at a circus everything is there
okay um what do you not get in a circus
yeah this is serious business ter books
uh books books yeah books a lawyer
reading
books reading we'll just we'll just uh
truncate those to totally one more um
you know the elderly F yeah that's good
I mean you love it young people like a
circus too but our two patrons are Lex
and Kevin smart they are
lovely
loyal and talented MH so make this
good and uh limited yeah let's do this
in uh let's keep the scene
short go all right Tara get ready for
this dramatic dramatic
at a circus chaotic yet vibrant
atmosphere uh stray peanut shells are
scattered everywhere in the background a
lawyer is deeply engrossed in reading
books while a snake charmer nearby
captivates a small audience French
acrobats prepare for their trapeze act
Lex a vivacious and talented gal and
Kevin smart a loyal and equally talented
Patron stand near The Cannonball setop
can you believe this a real life circus
it's like stepping into a story book
absolutely Lex and look at the
Cannonball dare me to give it a try only
if you promise not to end up needing
that lawyer over there speaking of which
isn't it odd to see someone reading so
intensely amidst all this chaos it's the
circus Lex everything and anything goes
but but hey check out those French
trapez artists they make flying look
easy they're amazing it's all about
balance Grace and bit of craziness kind
of like how we manage our lives right
absolutely spot on Lex uh speaking of
balance have you seen the Snake Charmer
it's mesmerizing how he moves with such
calm amidst all this madness true it's
all about charm and danger much like us
the super sexy rejects right absolutely
we're the Charming Risk Takers of our
own circus but hey let's be careful with
these peanut shells don't want to slip
before for our own act agreed let's
enjoy the show and maybe find a trapeze
to swing from after all what's life
without a little
Adventure wow and scene I read so much
subtext out of this this is definitely
like there's a lot going on in
between yeah of latent flirting
happening in the scene there's something
going on there so you know maybe this is
the Icebreaker you've been waiting for
to find true love through the patrion I
don't know if you know this this is also
a function of the patreon if you join
it's a love challenge yeah you might
find true love uh you know but but two
hey maybe you just find out that you
have a perfect professional working
relationship and that's hard to find too
you know like somebody you can perform
with and trust and know that they got
your back that's that's that's special
too so and that you don't love at all
yes but you get work done and boy oh boy
do you get emotional romantic love but
but you're very competent you're making
those checks most certainly and then
contributing them then to the patreon to
the patreon thank you guys we love you
and we'll catch you next month we love
you be well
[Music]
bye